sometimes people ask me can you choose
to be present from one perspective you
can choose to be present from another
perspective presence chooses you it
chooses to become present through you
depends how you look at it only when you
try to run away from the fear that
really it becomes a great obstacle but
if you can be with the fear allow the
fear to be there as on a pure energy
level Feel the fear then you will find
it begins to dissolve first you see the
need to be a victim identity also
unfortunately is a form of ego because
any conceptual identity is a form of ego
and even though you seem to be justified
in having a victim identity because of
the things that other humans did to you
you are finding yourself in a kind of
prison created by your mind need
motivation watch a top 10 with believe
Nation hey it's Evan Carmichael and I
make these videos because when I started
my first business I really struggled to
believe myself I was making 300 bucks a
month and quit I'm a business partner
and the thing that saved me was watching
the stories of successful entrepreneurs
they gave me strategies as well as hope
and belief that just maybe I could do it
myself as well and I hope that this
video here today helps you get a little
bit more belief in yourself because I
still need the videos for myself today
too so today let's learn from one of the
best Eckhart Tolle and my take on his
top 10 was a success
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one learn to say no I often say say yes
to the present moment
or I say
make the present moment your friend not
your enemy
so it's a to say yes to the present
moment is a powerful teaching but it can
be misunderstood and it has been
misunderstood sometimes and it needs to
be explained what that actually means it
means
okay oh by the way um
there's a funny movie made a few some
years ago with Jim Carrey it's called
the Yes Man
and this is a person in the movie a
character the character he plays
he works at a bank I think to in the
mortgage department and he's very he's
very bitter and he likes to say no to
people who apply for mortgages every no
you can't have any Lovesick and it's
very negative about everything now his
life is
the uneventful boring is everything is
negative then he goes to a new age
a friend invites him to a strange New
Age event with a new age teacher and the
teacher says you have to say yes
to everything say yes to everything and
he kind of
becomes convinced well I might as well
try that I've got nothing to lose
and from then on whatever people ask him
every mortgage he approves and whatever
people ask him can you lend me money
sure yes can you do this yes yes yes yes
and then his life becomes very
interesting but also very chaotic he
gets into most chaotic situations and he
kind of all gets out of hand and
I
at in the end he kind of seems to
realize that this wasn't quite working
it's that that was that is not the true
meaning
so to say yes to the present moment does
not mean that you accept everything that
people ask of you
in some cases you have to use the now
the no
but in the
um non but not
in an angry way that denies the present
moment I call that
a high quality no
so it's let's say
um in the August can you look after my
children or let's begin because I I need
you you're so so good with certain the
the seal flatter you you feel obliged
you're such a wonderful person I say I
love you can you do it again please and
at some point safety I'm sorry I can't
do it anymore
um but without
any negativity a simple statement it is
not a reactive statement you don't make
her into a bad person I know she you
want to take advantage of me I'm not
doing it anymore that is a low quality
now
even if perhaps you she did try to
perhaps she was trying to take advantage
of you but that is not that maybe then a
dysfunction in her egoic self many
humans do that the world is full of
people who perhaps are trying to take
advantage of you that's what the egos do
and so it is not who she truly is but
you speak to you you do not speak to the
ego in her you simply say
I love your children they're just
wonderful and I enjoyed my time but I
can't do it anymore I'm sorry about that
high quality no no no I can't do that a
person says can you lend me another
thousand dollars
um I need to well I've already lent you
a two thousand two three months ago and
last year I lent you five thousand I
haven't got anything back yet
and then it's I'm sorry I have to say no
but you don't say
did you just you're just trying to
accuse me
and I'm not going to do that anymore I'm
not going to be used anymore by you this
is it that's it I know more that that's
another kind of no but it's a low
quality no
and the high quality knows no I'm sorry
that's it I can't do that anymore this
it it reply it implies there's a
presence behind what you say it's not
reactive
and with the same the person who asked
you to write something you say I've seen
the background I'm not in agreement with
that therefore I'm sorry I need to say
no to this I can't do this thank you
high quality knobs it's beautiful and it
works so quite often you may have to use
that make sure that it's not reactive
and then becomes low quality rule number
two is manage your fears when I meditate
extreme fear often arises in my mind I
feel like I would be destroyed or
completely disappeared so I stopped
meditation because of the fear I'm so
afraid to keep going on although
intuitively know that bearing the fear
would get me closer to Enlightenment how
can I conquer this fear
this is yes of course the fear of the
person the personalized sense of self or
the ego
which can feel
threatened
by the arising awareness and once you
know that
you can still meditate and allow the
fear to be there it's only when you try
to run away from the fear that really it
becomes a great obstacle
but if you can be with the fear allow
the fear to be there as on a pure energy
level Feel the fear
then
you will find it begins to dissolve
so rather than not wanting to feel it
allow yourself to feel it
this beginning of change
if you always run away from it
then
it'll linger there's no change
there's a book called think feel the
fear and do it anyway or something like
that but that is a quite good advice
although I mean not applied necessarily
to everything
I'm going to jump off now
but to allow yourself to feel whatever
feeling comes is part of the present the
what the is-ness of the present moment
so if the fear Rises but then you also
realize what is is the fear created by a
thought you will know that or is the
fear arising just by itself in a
particular situation when you become
still
do you have a fear of Silence
do you feel uncomfortable when you go
into a room and there's there's no noise
in it some people do feel some people
are uncomfortable in nature
it's not noisy enough
so see it may be that the fear arises
when you when you become still you
meditate then it's not necessarily
associated with the thought but with
that arising of awareness and instead of
break just stopping your meditation
just what happens if I just carry on and
make the fear into a meditation meditate
on the fear so in when if you do
meditate
nothing really can disturb you with the
good meditator
incorporates whatever arises in the
present moment into the meditation
including the most irritating noise that
suddenly starts up outside
and the mind says I can't meditate now
I need Stillness and then you realize no
perhaps this is part of the meditation
and how does it become part of the
meditation
by allowing the isness of this moment
which is that by just letting go of
resistance allow whatever it is to be
and if it comes from within
fear anxiety you allow that to be but
you have to be careful that it doesn't
become a thought
because the moment you are drawn back
into thinking that's the end of your
meditation
you can allow a thought to be there but
to order to allow a soul to be there
that that
implies that there is some awareness
there
behind the thoughts or you are still
if so to be able it's a wonderful thing
do you allow the thought to be that's
very different from being drawn into the
thought and following it where it wants
to take you of course that's the end of
your meditation or your mindfulness or
whatever you want to call it I don't use
mindfulness as you know because
it's not about a full mind
that's why I avoid the word mindfulness
but mindfulness is a lovely thing it's
really its presence
so you can follow a sword it takes it
grabs you it grabs all your attention
and pulls you along that's one way
or you can realize this is authorizing
about
what my ex-spouse did five years ago to
me
while I'm meditating
and you can allow the thoughts to arise
and to be aware and if you do that
instead of being pulled into it then you
will find that it quickly it arises and
it sides so then it becomes very much
like you know the sky
in response let's say you have a blue
sky and clouds occasionally come so the
clouds are the thoughts that arise in
the mind
the blue skies the vastness of that
space is your awareness
so clouds are not a problem if
within the larger context of the aware
presence
they come and go and there might be
thoughts that say ridiculous things
there might be a thought about
I'd like to eat a
apple pie now I really need to eat apple
pie the mica is the most absurd things
to interrupt your meditation
can you imagine an apple pie you're
eating
and then you know there's the thought of
apple pie you allow that to be you don't
get drawn into the apple pie thought or
even suddenly you have to get up and run
to the fridge to see if they said they
have a pine still in there
a later the thought arises you are the
sky that's the awareness
and the thought is what comes into the
awareness now if more and more thoughts
come
or if you follow one of the cloud
thoughts that drift into the space of
awareness one of the cloud thoughts and
you suddenly go it it it grabs hold of
you and you follow it and the cloud gets
bigger
then it attracts other clouds that
correspond to it they suddenly come from
out of nowhere
and then you are in a big cloud you're
still sitting there trying to meditate
but you're really in a big cloud of
thought
and before you know it
the entire sky is
cloudy all totally overcast
now of course there's still some light
shining through the clouds but you'd no
longer know where that comes from
there's some light of of course
Consciousness sword cannot exist without
Consciousness thought is a manifestation
of consciousness
but so there's the Consciousness that is
behind the thoughts but you don't no
longer know that Consciousness directly
only through the filter of thoughts in
the same way that you don't know the
sunlight anymore except to the filter of
the clouds rule number three is shift
your perspective I'm surprised there's
nothing on Google about Eckhart and free
will but maybe maybe I haven't said
anything about it
uh
so here we go
as you know it's an it's an eternal
ancient philosophical question and
there's never been a definitive answer
but but that everybody would agree with
in that sense
so is there Australia you mentioned
everybody is doing their best because
every nobody can act beyond their level
of Consciousness etc for example okay
let's start from on one level
uh
and then we go on to the next level
on on the level of egoic
unconsciousness where you are a
conditioned entity your your mental
emotional makeup extra totally
conditioned by the past
and you are completely identified with
the conditioning of your of your mind
and in that state that spiritually
speaking is the unconscious state it is
obvious that in that state there is no
Freedom at all because you are forced to
act out the unconscious conditioning of
your mind with which you are completely
identified
so as most people would probably agree
if you understand
that that on that level
there is no possibility of Freedom their
actions are determined by the
unconditioned mind you are forced to act
as you do because there's no choice
because choice would imply some
awareness
so on that level there's certainly no
Freedom then
awareness comes in the human being
begins to awaken
then it appears I'm not saying it is the
case it appears that then the human the
free Freedom
begins to be a possibility because
you can
choose
to step out of the conditioning of your
mind you can recognize a conditioned
thought
and do you are no longer compelled to
act it out because there is an awareness
there you can choose a certain cause of
action not not from the conditioning of
your mind but from the the presence so
you can you can you can act and you have
much more freedom that before you could
not have freedom comes with
awareness
so it's then relative to the unconscious
day there is now freedom to act
but
if you look more deeply even there
even there on that level you are
connected with the totality of
Consciousness you're only an expression
of the totality of Consciousness you are
not really a separate entity you are a
like a who said it you are was it Alan
Watts who said you are you in the same
way that the the wave is something that
the ocean is doing
you are something that the whole
universe is doing in the same same way
so the wave is something the ocean is
doing you are something that the
universe is doing so although it appears
from a certain relative to the previous
state of unconsciousness there is
freedom and relative to that there is
freedom but then if you look more deeply
into that you realize that even there
one cannot say that you are choosing
this speak you are an expression of
Consciousness and Consciousness one
could say is choosing and you think
you're doing it sometimes people ask me
can you choose to be present
and you know from one perspective you
can choose to be present
from another perspective
one could say that
the presence chooses you it chooses to
become present through you depends how
you look at it
uh so in Ultimate terms or the in
relative terms there is freedom relative
to the unconscious State when you become
more conscious but even there it's only
relative to the unconscious State even
there there is no not absolute freedom
because you do not exist as an
independent entity you have a part of
the web of interconnectedness that is
the whole universe so in that sense
there is no freedom of choice of the
individual because ultimately there is
no individual rule number four is focus
your attention I have the main focus of
your attention
in your daily life
in the present moment
the rest of your attentions of that say
the main focus here is this
the rest of your attention is
where you want to go to your whatever
task you're engaged in has a certain
purpose
the purpose is you want to finish the
task then it has achieved its purpose
and that's here
and that's in the in your peripheral the
peripheral vision of your Consciousness
that's where you want to get to
and this is what you're doing in order
to get there
and your main attention is not
where you want to get and in the
meantime you're just doing it in order
to get there you can see how that's
already creates an inner stress
I'm here but I want to be there that's a
normal way of living is
the main part of people's attention is
there but in the meantime they are here
where they don't really want to be
to rather be there
at as shown in the famous
stickers on bumper stickers on cars
which say something like I'd rather be
fishing
cheat just for this video the worksheet
will highlight all the Lessons Learned
in this video as well as pull out our
three favorite learnings and quotes that
will inspire you to actually do
something the worksheet will also give
you space to write down what your key
takeaways are and your specific plan of
action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
rule number five is connect with people
the sense of being an outsider is also
something that
I have had
throughout my life
and
the sense of
not belonging here
watching my parents
being engaged
in continuous
conflict
not because they were bad people they
were they did what they did and they
loved me as best they could
and they did what they did
as a reflection of their state of
consciousness at that time which was a
normal State of Consciousness egoic
state of consciousness
but I sometimes felt how did I get here
somehow didn't there must have been a
mistake
um
it's often
Outsiders
on as being feeling an outsider on the
one hand is
seems a terrible limitation that you
can't participate
as much on the other hand it's a great
opportunity because
some of the most creative people
in the world have where have been
Outsiders they did not fit in
uh Misfits it's the English word and
misfits
um
another the friendships I had
when I was a child
and that's another interesting thing I
had to
friend one of my friends was it was
severely
physically
disabled
and nobody else wanted to
be friends with him because of that and
he was probably my closest friend
and the other one was so weird that
nobody wanted to talk to him and
but he became my friend so they were
Outsiders too
and
dot but the interesting fact here as you
know I couldn't believe it when they
told me
that there are people here from 70
countries it seems almost unbelievable
but it's true I saw the list
70 countries and you may find I'm sure
you will find
quite often
uh you you you can feel a bond or you
have more in common
with many of the people who are here
then you have with your own people in
your own country at home who are not
going through any Spiritual Awakening
who are still totally conditioned 100
conditioned by their culture so you feel
a connectedness here with other humans
that transcends culture and conditioning
and all this silly political stuff it
transcends that and this is a wonderful
thing
so to some extent you can now connect
with people even if you don't always see
them physically where you might live I
don't know whether you live in a big
city or a small village
City small City yeah yeah world city in
spoke in Austria oh yes yeah nice very
nice
I don't know how many people in
Innsbruck are 120
000 and how many of those are
Awakening we don't know
we don't know of course
but this helps I believe being here and
feeling you are not alone
you are connected
so this should be helped for the rest
you just have to accept that this is how
it is
and no matter how hard you try to fit in
on the normal level you probably won't
nor do you have to so I know this there
are many people here who feel that and
be happy with it but don't make it into
some kind of superiority because the ego
can always creep in
before you know it there's always a back
door and then the ego is back in so you
can you could go from feeling bad about
being an outsider to suddenly feeling
okay I'm an outsider because I'm
superior
and then so to have to be careful don't
go there so
um
that's just how it is if you you
probably would not be here
if you had not been an outfelt like an
outsider for many years so it worked
rule number six is free your mind you
won't really enjoy the fruit of your
labors
if habitually you cannot be present in
the moment
no matter what you achieve the enjoyment
will be short-lived because of the
habitual pattern
of dissatisfaction in the background
it's always there some obscure sense of
lack and often it comes into the
foreground There's real unhappiness
frustration
and then if you realize that there's
always this waiting for the next thing
which is thought when you're waiting for
the next thing you're trapped in thought
because that's where future happens
now
the realization that this is happening
to you is very important the first step
is the beginning of something else
arising
and in all of you that has already
Arisen or that occasionally it still
gets obscured perhaps probably I assume
something else has arisen that's not
thought that is beyond thought the
ability to recognize thought
the ability to recognize certain
patterns that habitually arise in your
mind your mental emotional field
the ability to witness that which arises
in your mental emotional field
that's an enormous
believe in consciousness
another dimension one could say has
arisen
we could call it presence we could call
it awareness
it's not thought
but its intelligence
so intelligence is not confined to
thought
there is a dimension in you
that is far
greater far more intelligence than any
intelligent thought
it's the place from where all
intelligence arises a place of where all
creativity arises
[Music]
foreign
to suddenly be aware of your inner
states to be aware of what your mind is
saying the The Narrative the habitual
narrative that you're telling yourself
you're having a monologue or many people
have a dialogue with themselves where
they split themselves in two and then
this one argues with the other why
aren't you good enough why did you do
this why do you never get anything right
we shouldn't have he shouldn't have said
that yes but on the other so you can
have a dialogue in your narrative or you
can have a monologue it says I am such a
miserable creature because a lot of the
time the narratives the unconscious
thought processes tend to be more
negative than positive for many many
people
so to be aware that this is happening
that's an enormous gain in continence
it's the beginning of Awakening oh
spiritually speaking
something arises that is not part of the
conditioned mind patterns
so there's the ability to observe your
inner states and that's a wonderful
little pointer to ask yourself
[Music]
frequently
wants my inner State at this moment
and then look at it direct your
attention to it the narratives what have
I been telling myself
and the emotion that accompanies The
Narrative
what am I feeling what's the emotion
so in addition to it being a story in
your head and an emotion
there's a knowing
behind it
there's a space behind it
sometimes I call it Inner Space better
than Inner Space
from where you can be aware of what's
Happening
on the level of the person the
personality
because that Inner Space the awareness
is not part of the personality it's but
it's the being
the knowing that it's inherent in the
being rule number seven is learn to
forgive you can look at the world wars
you can look at all the the terrorism
and all the other mad Wars that are
being fought
as just
it's just a question of degrees of
unconsciousness not different
so when you go into that state of
unconsciousness you it takes you over
you lose it
basically then that is the same energy
field
that has created
what we see as the Mad Madness of human
history
and what we see of The Madness of the
so-called world news
the same energy so don't complain about
all these violent people who are doing
all these Dreadful things all that it is
is human or unconsciousness in a more
pronounced form than yours
or your partners
and
so
that helps a little bit to find perhaps
almost some compassion
towards
all these crazy people
that are doing such crazy things and
creating such terrible suffering now if
you become compassionate towards them
don't worry
it doesn't mean that they will not
experience
the consequences of their
unconsciousness that still happens you
just by being compassionate to another
human being you don't necessarily remove
the karmic consequences of their action
but
you yourself
become free from the
from being drawn into the karmic cycle
so the
the act of forgiveness
does not mean
that this person is not going to suffer
the consequences but life makes sure in
whatever form that they do suffer the
consequences of the suffering that they
inflict on other human beings it's a
karmic law
but if you don't want to be part of that
anymore if you want to step out of the
karmic law the the first step out of the
and the most important step out of the
karmic law is forgiveness
then you do not feed it you don't become
part of it that's why traditionally in
spiritual teachings of various
traditions
forgiveness is always emphasized it must
be real though it's there are many forms
of superficial forgiveness when Justin
Martin is okay I forgive you it's not
deep it's not real yet
the mind is trying to forgive but you
you can only forgive
if you realize that whatever actions
have been perpetrated are the effects of
human unconsciousness
in other words what Jesus said on the
cross or is reported to have said
forgive them for they know not what they
do
very profound statement it is a profound
statement that can be applied to any Act
of
violence perpetrated against other
humans or life forms forgive them for
they know not what they do
not knowing what they do of course means
they are unconscious
the word unconscious probably in that
sense wasn't used at the time
so he said they don't know what they do
karmic law still operates
but without you
and you can notice karmic law
[Music]
when when you see a movie some movies
like to manipulate your emotions
and so there are particular types of
movies where they first they build up
the tension by showing you some very
evil persons
and this evil person is killing all
these people or hurting all these people
and then you're being manipulated
to feel that incredible pull that this
person should suffer for what he or she
has done that's the manipulation the
audience loves it they love watching
things like that
so then the emotion builds up and
finally there even some movies like The
the movies that uh about um
Vigilantes who take justice in their own
hands because the justice system doesn't
deal with the criminals anymore so
finally you have this guy who goes out
and kills all the bad guys and the your
emotions have been manipulated so much
that the audience that yes yes he must
die not realize no what you what you are
feel what what you are feeling this
incredible it might also happen if you
read about some Dreadful crime that
somebody has committed and then if you
read it on the internet the you can read
in some on some news websites you can
read the comment section
and in the comment section on every
other comment says we should have the
death penalty who needs to say electric
chair he needs to be
done to what he did did he they should
do to him and all these and this is an
enormous pressure that people feel
inside and this is connected to karmic
law because there is a compensatory
factor in karmic law and you can feel
that as the pressure inside you but it
keeps you trapped in karma
huh so in that sense watching these
movies is not helpful
because it keeps you trapped in that
that wheel of karma
so they don't teach forgiveness there so
this is we are talking it's about
something very important and that is
dealing with human unconsciousness and
what looks like evil
they saw there are many things that are
quite Dreadful so how do we how does
that affect our state of consciousness
and what role does our state of
consciousness play in this whole
scenario it does have a role to play
and so it's
for us
important
that we are no longer part of
action and reaction because the
definition of karma is action comma
means action and reaction and it goes on
and on and as you can see in certain
societies and so on the karmic thing
goes on what goes back centuries and
centuries the same grievance
transmitted from one generation to the
next and the next and the next and they
are all asleep
this is why spiritual teaching say you
are asleep they are all so unconscious
they get taken over by the collective
mental emotional pattern and the mental
story they just inherited from their
parents and then they pass it on to
their children and then they and each
generation suffers they suffer they call
them suffering think right for each each
other
and at some point
the suffering becomes almost unbearable
for certain people within that society
and that's the beginning of
a shift when it gets too much so
suffering drives humans
to appoint
of Awakening it's a strange Paradox here
is
the suffering is created by the
unconsciousness in humans
but in some strange way
eventually it wakes you up it awakens
you
that's the redeeming feature behind the
suffering that humans create for each
other
eventually it leads to a spiritual
awakening
so
it always a good thing to realize it all
comes down to your state of
consciousness
and how you relate to the people around
you and that spreads that is what
creates the world
and even how you react to when you
listen to the world news
that has a certain influence because of
all
all human minds are connected at a
deeper level
so the way in which you react to what
you hear on the world news contributes
either to the unconsciousness if you get
on the on your computer or the iPad and
you type in this guy does not deserve to
live
[Music]
he should be
die slowly
then you become part of the same Karma
if you've ever done that please forgive
yourself
and if you enjoy reading those comments
also forgive yourself rule number eight
is take control certain actions take
place you do things you know
they are not
the optimal things to do but you can't
help it it's something
acts through you there's there seems to
be some power there that makes you do
things
that you know no are not right or not
good for you and yet you can't stop it
that seems to be the case
um
and that of course
is often the case with people who are
with you it might be many different
different areas of your life but
um
this is also the case with addictions
for example people are addicted to
a certain substance or who are addicted
to eating too much or drinking
there's something that overpowers them
in you that seems to obscure
the awareness
or the awareness is pushed to to recite
and this thinking this this powerful
thing does it anyway
and again my answer is a little bit
similar to
um
what I say to the first question tonight
the
the power of the presence
needs to grow in you so that
it is strong enough not to it's not
willpower because willpower is not
the best way of dealing with these
things but
it's what I'm talking about could
sometimes be confused with willpower but
willpower includes the application of a
force to hold something down let's say
um
if your addiction is to
have a to indulge in
intoxicating beverages in other words
booze is the British word then
and you can feel it it comes on there it
comes you know the bottles are there
there they are and you feel you have to
go then you have to reach out and you
have to pour yourself a drink now
when you're not aware at all you don't
even know what you're doing you're so
unconscious that you you're already
holding the drink and you're drinking
then you at that point you you even know
that you're drinking the same with food
I've spoken to people who've had
addictions to food they often say they
wake up when they're ready they've
already eaten in the middle of the night
they've already unconsciously gone to
the fridge taken out the chocolate cake
and then they're already halfway through
the chocolate cake and suddenly what am
I doing
but so awareness comes in at a very late
point
willpower would be to hold an urge down
that say I got they have to pull or even
what the example you gave you want to
turn on the TV and you know it it's not
right because I I'm not here for that
and he actually told us not to do it
help it I have to go I can't I can't no
willpower you would you would say I'm
going to hold this I'm not going to do
it
I can confirm the odds but you're
holding it down
[Laughter]
when you hold things down
often after a while
an explosion happens it's like a boiling
kettle
can't hold it for that long and then you
have some kind of rationalization in
your mind but it's you'll do it anyway
the mind will give you a reason rule
number nine is stop being a victim first
you see the need to be a victim identity
also unfortunately is a form of ego
because any conceptual identity is a
form of ego and even though you seem to
be employees justified in having a
victim identity because of the things
that other humans did to you you
yourself are finding you are finding
yourself in a kind of prison
that created by your mind
so there's no denial of that bad things
happen to you yes
now question is
how do you exit
this mental present
the first step is perhaps to see
[Music]
um
that
unconscious human beings
unconscious human beings in the grip of
their own conditioning their own ego
and
they have virtually no free will
when you are unconscious you are
controlled by
the the Mind patterns that are lodged in
your psyche
you have you cannot really speak of Free
Will by somebody who has zero awareness
and yet the entire makeup is uh
conditioning from the past
so the famous sentence phrase used by
Jesus
in connection with forgiveness on the
cross he said forgive them for they know
not what they do
now these these two interesting these
points put together
forgive them why forgive them
they know not what they do in other
words if he had spoken these days using
our terminology
he probably would have said they are
completely unconscious
because that's what it means they know
not what they do they are completely
unconscious
so when you see nobody can act beyond
their level of consciousness
then you see that it's almost like it
becomes almost like the evil that was
perpetrated becomes almost like a
natural phenomenon
that is like you've been hit by
lightning or something or
lived in very unpleasant
climatic conditions that that injured
you
near volcano
and my dad what had problems with anger
huge outbursts of anger quite frequently
it was living like living the legs
through a volcano they could erupt at
any moment
um
and he could not help it it was it was
impossible there was no possibility of
being different
and so these humans are run by
unconscious conditioning usually goes
back to their childhood and what
happened there
I know why my father was angry I I
needed I realized much later that it all
originated in his childhood the the
reasons why he was so angry and also
for a while also I felt a resentment
towards that and only when I was able to
awaken out of egoic consciousness
I saw that there's nothing that he could
have done differently because there
wasn't enough awareness
now
when you see that then you don't
personalize or you don't create an
identity for other humans out of their
unconsciousness because in essence
that's not who they are the recognition
that there's first recognition and step
one you recognize that no human can act
beyond their conditioning
in the absence of awareness
if there's awareness they can transcend
their conditioning and then they begin
to become conscious of their own
conditioned mental emotional
dysfunctional mental emotional patterns
yes
so they couldn't
they can't help it so that's that's
already a useful step in forgiveness but
it you may not yet be able to arrive at
at full forgiveness because of that
another before I continue with that
does that mean then a question may arise
in your mind
doesn't mean then humans are not really
responsible for what they do
if they are unconscious how are they
responding does that mean then that we
shouldn't punish them from what they do
if they commit a crime
are they not guilty
that's an interesting question
the
the unconsciousness
that operates in human even if you are
able to forgive a human when we come we
will go more fully into that in a minute
even if you're able to forgive and human
for their transgressions or whatever
they did
this does not mean and even though the
human is not responsible for their
unconsciousness and yet
it is built into the
structure of human life
they still need to suffer the
consequences of their unconsciousness
and Rule Number 10 the last one before
some very special bonus Clips is know
yourself is religion necessary it
depends who you are on the level of the
form for some people it can be necessary
or helpful
for two reasons
it can provide the more superficial
reason
it can give your life a certain amount
of structure which for some people can
be helpful
regular practice
gives you feeling of comfort
some people have too little structure in
their lives and others have too much
already
if you have too little structure in your
life then religion can provide that
more importantly on another level
religion can either obscure
the
spiritual Dimension within yourself and
often it does
or
if used rightly if approached rightly if
understood
on a deeper level
it can
help you
access and stay in connectedness
with that deeper level of yourself or
the Transcendent dimension of
consciousness
whether or not you need it only you can
know whether you find it either helpful
or a hindrance
we can be either depend depends on
you as a person your past what function
it had in your past
and so on
it is a hindrance
if religion becomes an ideology
then it operates only on the level of
the Mind
and it's very similar to any other kind
of ideology that you may believe in
whether it's
communism as a as an ideology or any
political theory of anything that
explains the universe it could be a
metaphysical system that you completely
believe in
philosophical system and so on
so an ideology is something that takes
possession of your mind
and exerts a controlling function
[Music]
and it can influence
almost the entire mental functioning if
it becomes something of a
overwhelming power in your mind it's a
it's a little thought that grows into a
huge thing in your mind and the
tentacles breeds into every aspect of
your mind and there are religious people
like that
uh
usually you can recognize that it is an
ideology
by the fact that they are not peaceful
human beings
and by the fact that
they have
enemies
either even within their own religion
or another religion anybody who does not
agree with their ideology
becomes an enemy in the same way the
people who were not nowadays that many
were deeply believing in communism which
was a wonderful idea to start with of
course
the road to hell is paved with good
intentions it was a beautiful idea of
equality
everybody the same that is wonderful no
personal possessions so it's wonderful
too
and the only mistake was
it was imposed from outside by people
who themselves has not gone beyond the
egoic State of Consciousness they just
played it in their mind isn't that's a
good idea
and then it was imposed on on other
people who also were not in that state
of consciousness but most importantly
those who impose the idea on others
forced them to live it out
the ideal became contaminated with ego
so when these people came to power
the egos
became inflated to an enormous degree
almost to absurdity and without
realizing it
they
re-enacted
the same
evils in some cases worse than those
that they were fighting against
the Transcendence of thinking means the
Transcendence of the egoic Mind
it means that
you are able
to
spend part of your time
relatively free of compulsive thinking
certainly free of self-serving thinking
and destructive thinking that
continuously creates unhappiness for
yourself and the people around you
how many people lived in the compulsive
narrative in your mind that for many
people is very negative constantly
critical constantly complaining never at
ease with what is there's always
something wrong fault finding because
the ego grows through the constant
opposition
constant antagonism
never at ease
always looking for the next thing to
complain about
and its strengthens the ego itself the
it the more you complain oh
offended is a new version these days
it's very popular on the internet
I'm very very offended
outrageous how dare you
oh
there are thousands or hundreds of
thousands that you go on every day they
look on your their screen waiting for
the next scene to be offended by
and the ego loves it
and for many of them it's the only way
they can inflate their ego by sitting on
the screen and sending out tweets
the Transcendent of thinking is not
and any kind of regressive movement
we're not regressing to the state of
somebody who is
whose mind is relatively undeveloped
and who does not have a problem with
egoic thinking because there's very
little going on in their minds
what used to be called
before it became Politically Incorrect
idiot
or fool
uh
the fool was
they were always you could see a happy
fools there
they don't there's not enough thinking
to rank them unhappy so there's they are
below egoic thinking
in the medieval times every village had
at least one village idiot or fool and
they were normal was accepted essential
part of the community
uh
and even the Royal courts had a fool
very important figure
although that figure probably was just
pretending to be a fool and that was one
of the most sometimes very influential
position in the Royal Court
but also one of the most dangerous jobs
you could have
because you could lose your hand at any
moment but only the fool was able to
tell the king or queen what was wrong no
by making making it into a funny story
but the fool is more deeply connected
as we know wrong from mythology
the fool is more deeply connected with
the source still hasn't gone as far out
as a normally developed human he's more
simple
he a fool for example a relatively
speaking is a simpleton it's like The
Hobbit in Lord of the Rings
the The Hobbit
The Hobbit is a simple guy
um
doesn't should something in complex
terms loves the simple things of Life
loves eating and enjoyment
but why the fool has to go on this
important mission that nobody else can
carry out
that's a mythological motive that's
often the case because the fool is has a
connectedness still with source that the
more developed humans don't have
similar motive in Forrest Gump the movie
the food does great things this guy for
his company but he's
uh because he's and life always supports
him if he watch the movie again he
always he he saves people in the war he
does heroic things but he doesn't claim
credit because he doesn't have much of
an ego yet
and all his life gives him the next
thing and the next thing
supports him
but we don't want to go there when I say
cessation of thinking I'm not talking
about regressing to this to the stage it
is the pre-thinking stage
of humanity I'm thinking about Rising
above
pointing to the possibility of rising
above thinking
so you stop thinking
which is normally associated with
the diminishment of consciousness
and Transcendence of thinking is an
intensification of Consciousness turning
up the light this is why the term
attention and alertness those terms are
extremely important
they're also used in Zen very frequently
the Zen teachings could be described if
you wanted to summarize then
uh is what just because you can just say
simple things like pay attention
there was one zen teacher who would
whenever they asked him a question to
explain Zen
he was became quite famous
he we would always raise his finger
please explain Zen to us
what is saying I haven't quite
understood yet
[Music]
he was calling people to attention now
this attention there's a state of
attention that sometimes people
experience when they are engaged in
dangerous activity you can climb a
mountain
do you think do you think you're doing
much thinking when you're hanging on
this wall no you can't you have to be
absolutely present in that moment you
have transcended thinking and the
situation has forced you is forcing you
into complete presence this highest
degree of alertness
without it you slip and you're gone
and so this High degree of Learners
however has no has no tension in it in
this in the case of somebody practicing
the dangerous spot yes there is physical
tension but the the state itself has no
tension in it and you do not need to
engage in a dangerous activity in order
to
enter that state we are entering it here
because even as I talk about it
thank you
I hope well I don't really hope anything
but I I trust that
as I speak about it
simultaneously simultaneously to
listening to it you can
verify in yourself this state of
attention which is a state of very high
alertness but there's no tension in it
it's not the alertness that is sometimes
goes with fear then you go but it's not
that's really a contraction of the
entire body
it's it's not really alertness it's
so that's not it it's a very it's a
relaxed alertness
in it
coming together
and it's it's that
if you I just also mentioned the other
day when you first look at something for
the first few seconds
a new Vista a new landscape you enter a
room or you step out of a room into the
open or whatever it is or suddenly
something new comes into your field of
into your perceptual field in the first
two or three seconds you you don't know
what it is you have to First Take it in
there's a moment of a large presence in
this but usually you're only aware of
the sense perception you're not aware of
the background of the alert presence
itself
but you can be aware of the alert
presence itself as you take it in
and that's the key
so you're not just alertly present
you're aware of the field of alert
presence in yourself so to speak as
yourself
and the awareness
of it and it are the same thing
cessation of thinking
now
you can try it let's
even now I would suggest that as I'm
speaking
you may find you may not know this
yet
in the moments when I'm not speaking
like now
and now
if you're alert you're not thinking
you're just present
and now
there's just an alert field of presence
so
some of you
may not be able yet to be totally free
of thinking but I believe that most
people are able to vote where they have
short gaps of north or pure awareness or
no thought just to show
and then you look around
in that moment
your whole
your personal sense of self has receded
in the moment of pure presence which is
just this
you have no memories and you have no
expectations for future yeah because you
have no thought
but you're not you haven't fallen asleep
you're very awake
in that moment you're not a person
anymore
what are you
just a field of Consciousness conscious
presence something has
emerged from within you
and has taken place of the person
is still there it's just gone receded
if the only thing you
achieve in life
is this
that you are able to
be can't be free of compulsive and
addictive thinking if you're able to
almost one could say to choose
not to think when there's nothing in
particular to think about
when it can just be present
so in other words
if you can step out of thinking into
aware presence that alert space
then
that is the greatest thing you could
achieve in this lifetime that any human
could achieve in this lifetime and yet
there's nobody left to say I have
achieved it that's the problem for the
ego the ego would love to say oh I have
achieved the state of of presence thank
you
so it's not an achievement I'm just
saying it's an achievement but it's not
really
because you didn't do it you got out of
the way and then it happened the usual
mistake of dysfunctional way of living
unconscious way is as I've mentioned
before is devaluing the present moment
and all the valuing the next moment ego
lives always with reference to past and
future the mentally are always somewhere
else instead of giving fullest attention
to this because this is the most
valuable moment why because it's the
only one the present moment give your
fullest attention to this moment because
it's not true that the next moment is
more significant because it never comes
so there is a way of being totally
present in the planning for the next for
the future it's all little things and
evenly whoever if you're the pope or the
president of a huge corporation or the
president of a country but still the
same the present moment in its richness
that is usually overlooked because
you're looking for something more
significant
it's not it's it's fine to achieve
things especially if they are beneficial
but for Humanity and the totality on the
planet
it's lovely to have that
but they don't even that doesn't make up
your identity the more you honor the
small things
the more likely it is that you'll
experience
more good things in the so-called future
because you have such a good
relationship with the present the
Gratitude is an underlying
State of Consciousness which is giving
your fullest attention honoring
what is
the the power to manifest is in
experiencing
the
[Music]
fullness
of the present moment the
undifferentiated fullness
told
when you don't complain about not only
not other people but also about your
life
and you can't be a victim anymore I is
the light of Consciousness in which
these feelings are being experienced
right now the victim
is a is a huge a huge prison it's not it
is not who you are and remember
thanks for everything
I have no complaint whatsoever
saw this this wonderful Stillness here
and
let's
acknowledge it
the power is not just in you it's all
around you so you need to realize most
humans have this inbuilt dysfunction
they cannot acknowledge the present
moment
unconsciously they regard the next
moment with if it's a minute from now
or an hour from now or two years from
now always regarded as more important
whenever you are impatient trying to get
somewhere waiting for something
impatiently what's the next thing I have
to do and I have to do that and you're
pulled in all kinds of directions what's
now oh now I have to do that and that
and that and there's always the pull to
the what's the next thing
uh
that is I call that sometimes
you lose yourself in doing
is necessary obviously you need to do
but to lose yourself in continuous doing
is a serious dysfunction but it's so
normal that nobody realizes it
so what if you lose yourself in the
doing there's always another and this is
how stress arises
but stress is the gap in the gap between
now
and later the projected then now and
then in that Gap arises this stress
arises so the mental projection towards
future creates the stresses between you
well I'm here but I want to be there
and for many humans
that is their predominant State they are
always they are here but they don't they
really want to be there either they're
in space or time
It's amazing And even you Awakening
beings
may still
sometimes or often
find yourself in that state where you'd
suddenly realize that the whole day
you've been stressed about this that and
that and that is the world to make
someone demands upon you need to deal
with this and this and this Amplified by
the gadgets that we now use which is an
amplification of the dysfunction through
this
yeah
and you lose yourself in the doing you
become completely
unscented and and
basically lost their many uh even it
happens even to Children already at an
early age these days
and many children are suffering from
attention deficit disorder and so on
which means that their mind is being
pulled and always away from the present
moment
so lost in doing
lost in doing
really comes back to
lost in thinking
thinking underlies doing so you are lost
in your thoughts
about the world
and then you engage in all kinds of
activities propelled by
thought that I know I need to do this
now I need to do that
so the basic condition still from most
humans on the planet
so
fundamentally yes they are lost in doing
they lose their health into but
basically it means they are lost in
their mind in the movement of thought
you identify them they identify with
every thought that arises in this many
thoughts are about future
all the past not that many thoughts
about the present moment and if they are
about the present moment then it is an
interpretation of the present moment
that is completely
determined and colored by your past
conditioning
so very interesting
to observe in oneself
this tendency
to deny
devalue
disregard reduce the present moment to a
means to an end it's always a means to
an end but it's another
recognized for what it is in itself
and often it is not it is more than a
means to an end from many humans
this is a very dysfunctional way of
being
for many humans the present moment is
actually regarded unconsciously as an
obstacle that they need to get Beyond
this Con continuous underlying unease
and what's the next thing that is going
to go wrong I know it's going to happen
lost lost in the mind lost in thought
there was an Indian teacher who
described the essential human condition
as lost in thought and of course that's
how it is this is then this movement of
thought
gives you your sense of identity then
then the the unease the the uneasy
narrative the problematic Narrative of
me and my life I have to think about
this when I wake up in the middle of the
night
and I carry this heavy burden of my
problematic life for many humans the
identity is unconsciously regarded as a
problem to be solved
I am a problem that I'm looking for a
solution
to this problem that I am
and of course then you go to a therapist
now if the therapist is good he might be
able to take you beyond that
depends
if he or she is not good then you get
more deeply entrenched and 15 years
later you are still undergoing
psychoanalysis and finds ever deeper
layers of complexity in your past
and there's no end to it
so
the present moment
is devalue
not recognized
regarded either as a means to an end or
an obstacle
that is the for many humans that is
their predominant state of mental
emotional state
and
as I said the identities derived from
that so it's the the
the error lies in
identification with thought now the
question arises
who or what is it that identifies with
thought if I am not the story that I
tell myself about who I am
if I am not ultimately that
then who or what am I
and what is it in me that that
identifies with the story what is it
that creates this
sense of identity
that is mostly
exists mostly in a state of unease
or very often discontent
because it cannot
acknowledge the present moment
that is the ego by the way that's what
we call it the the egoic sense of self
there's a very simple spiritual practice
to get you to the realization of who or
what it is that identifies I suggest at
this moment
that
observe yourself internally right now
to see if there's any
lingering emotion in you perhaps from
earlier today or an hour ago or
yesterday
or the past two years
or the past
10 years is there any and can you feel
for example if any is an irritation
somewhere is there some kind of anxiety
is there
kind of
heaviness a certain heavy mood
a despondent mode perhaps is it
lingering there
is there anger anger big thing some
residue of Anger from what happened
earlier is that in you and then normally
humans would say
I am angry or they would say
I am anxious I'm fearful
I am
in a bad mood
now there's already a delusion when the
moment you say I am angry or I am
anxious
that indicates already that you have
identified with the emotion of anger or
the emotion of
sadness or the emotion of fear
you have identified you equate I with
what arises in your field of
consciousness
so you say I'm angry
it would be more correct to say
there's anger in me right now
it may sound a trivial
difference between saying I am angry and
there's anger in me but there's a
significant difference which goes beyond
mere
syntax how you put words together
because when you say I am you equate I
with whatever condition is there in you
this applies to emotion and it also
applies to a thought
when because anger is often it's not
just the anger as emotion the anger also
exists as a angry thoughts and then they
they if they reinforce each other as a
vicious circle when you when they when
you are trapped in irritation or anger
the emotion feeds the thought and the
thought feeds more energy to the emotion
it's a vicious circle
and you don't want to get out of it you
might notice when you
observe an angry person or or despondent
person on anxious person
They Don't Really Want to Be Free of the
anger they don't want their turn
if you suggest it to the angry person
you can be free you will not get a
pleasant answer
and you you've seen angry people who
they are in the grip of anger or
irritation they cannot help it then they
shout at you and then they leave the
room and the minute later the door opens
they come back because they're sort of
something else to insult your birth
they
are in the grip of it there is a
complete identification with thought and
emotion
they are lost in thought they are Lost
in Emotion but who or what is it that is
lost
if I'm not the thoughts and the emotion
who or what am I
okay
I just asked you to just have a look
inside yourself and see what it is if
there's anything there that's jarring
and doesn't feel good but it's there
and I'm not saying try to get rid of it
no
acknowledge the present moment the
present moment is what is
externally or internally
that's what is but there's a huge
difference now you've already by
recognizing that there is let's say
irritation anger or anxiety in you
an additional
element on Dimension has come in
and that Dimension we could call
awareness
or we could call it presence
and the moment awareness comes in
you are no longer completely identified
with it one could say I sometimes
describe it as let's say there's the
anger
and as your awareness of the anger comes
in
there's a little bit of space around it
let's see awareness the awareness knows
that there's anger
the anger may still be there it may not
immediately disappear but the awareness
knows it's there
or whatever else it may be the arising
of awareness is spiritual awakening
the disidentification that happens
when awareness arises
that is
the spiritual awakening or the arising
of the Transcendent dimension of
Consciousness Transcendent because it
transcends
who
or what you are as a person you know
that you get defensive the question is
do you know in the moment of getting
defensive that you're defensive or do
you know it afterwards you can look into
that
I'm rarely content or grateful
that's interesting that's very good self
observation too
I'm not content at this moment I'm not
content
my thinking is so negative another good
piece of knowledge my thinking is
negative at this moment what are the
thoughts that are going through my head
so if you apply the awareness that is
already there hiding behind all these
things
if you apply the awareness
to the present moment when these things
arise defensiveness
what is low self-esteem it's something
that you
tell yourself about yourself in your
mind is certain repetitive thoughts that
the voice in the head tells you
those are this is certain low
self-esteem you there might be certain
emotions that go with it emotionally
but really those basis for low
self-esteem is something you tell
yourself about your low worth
its thoughts
now
the questioner already knows that she
has low self-esteem
and if she can know that she has lots of
scene in the moment of the low
self-esteem arising as as thoughts
she can recognize them as thoughts and
not necessarily true thoughts arising
repetitive thoughts that condition
thoughts perhaps this role self-esteem
might have started in childhood
it often happens to people whose parents
are very critical or parents tell them
you're never good enough this can be one
reason
so it might have started there it's a
conditioned way of thinking conditioned
thoughts now the awareness that's
already there in the questioner
would need to be there in the moment of
those things arising and then you can
see when three thoughts arise you
recognize them as
thoughts that are rising and you're no
longer completely trapped in what these
thoughts are saying
in other words to use an analogy that we
used not long ago
you can your sense of being is not in
the thought anymore it's in the
awareness of the thought in other words
if you look at the sky
the vast Sky daytime this time let's
look at the daytime Sky the vast the
vastness of the huge expansiveness of
the sky is awareness in this analogy and
clouds that come our thoughts
so when the clouds come why can't I
never do anything right why are other
people's more successful than me or I'm
not good at this when these thoughts
come instead of being drawn into those
clouds and then the clouds get bigger
and bigger
you remain the sky
and allow the clouds to pass and then to
pass away
and that means you begin to no longer
feel you're no longer feeding
conditioned thinking and you are
separating who you are you're taking
your identity out of thinking
thinking for a while has a daily
momentums old patterns will come again
and again but you're no longer renewing
them you're no longer feeding them by
how do you feed them by identifying with
every thought that comes there's a self
in it it's in so you separate yes you
are the awareness behind the thought
same applies to any kind of negative
thinking
you recognize it as
automatic
it arises and it's a thought
so but you are the awareness that knows
that this is a negative thought pattern
and if that can grow because it's
already there to some extent
if that grows which means deepens
then those condition patterns will
diminish they get transmuted
so
another one point here mentioned I get
defensive easily
defensive can happen happens very very
quickly in in human interactions the
defensiveness can come up so quickly
it's an automatic pattern
and you may only know it afterwards or
that was defensiveness again uh
and defensiveness and of course these
are all ego ways of the ego to protect
itself ego being the Mind Made itself
defensiveness will will just come up
with any
any lie just to keep its ego identity
intact so it'll come up with anything uh
just okay it's automatic
so
you can of Course in Miracles as a lies
lovely saying which is uh whenever you
become defensive about anything
know that you have identified with an
illusion you have identified yourself
with an illusion
that's interesting
is that true let's say
you say that
the distance from here to the Moon is
uh
I think in kilometers it's like 350 000
or so kilometers
and that the light takes just over one
second
to travel from the Moon to the Earth
and you know that for a fact well I know
that I haven't verified it myself but it
seems to be true
and somebody else says no that's
completely untrue
it actually takes one minute
it does
now this is just a difference of opinion
of viewpoint and of course you know very
well that the other person is wrong now
if you if you say no that's not right is
that defensiveness
well it depends how you say it the
question is are you identified with your
mind which has this position which
happens to be true but are you
identified
with that mental position in other words
is it do you derive your sense of self
from thought
if you identified with you will get
angry and defensive about the other
person who is so completely wrong and
you might say things like well if you
know that person well you always doubt
me why do you always doubt me you never
believe what I say do you
that's called defensiveness and that's
the ego trying to protect yourself and
then the cause and Miracle thing applies
know that when you become defensive
about anything know that you've
identified with yourself with an
illusion the illusion is not
that it takes one second for the light
from the Moon to travel to the Earth
it's not what the illusion is the
illusion is that you identified with a
sword
with a mind pattern and so you are
strengthening an illusory identity
[Laughter]
by identifying by strengthening the
mental position of me my mental position
that's unconscious
so this is how just a difference of
opinion can degenerate into huge
conflict just a small difference of
opinion because the ego becomes
defensive so that requires
alertness on your part so that you know
when it arises oh so whenever you become
defensive so without ego the same
conversation would go no it takes one
minute I know that for a fact the other
person says
it takes one second It Takes a Minute uh
well no you're wrong it takes one second
okay
well we'll leave it at that then I think
it's a second and you think it's a
minute
end of the story that would be without
without defensiveness or ego okay and
then you can go on on off where
everybody goes on the internet
and that would definitely solve it
dream forms of egoic unconsciousness you
will say what it says in Wikipedia is
wrong
it's wrong
they didn't get it right
that may bring me to another question or
just to end on this question the key is
your awareness
so that that deepens then all those
patterns that you mentioned will weaken
uh and there's already a considerable
amount of awareness in this person
the questioner the awareness of course
isn't the person but it's deeper than
the person
the thing is to apply the awareness to
the present moment when things arise not
in some abstract way I am a defensive
person will I ever become a person who
is not negative
I can't get rid of my negative patterns
I'm I'm so negative though it doesn't
matter let this moment is what matters
so just apply your awareness to this
moment you can't change things into
mental constructs how can I change
myself I don't want to be that kind of a
person anymore look at it
to this moment this is why you apply
presence
as I sometimes call it I haven't used
that expression in a while the sort of
presence that cuts through time and you
go
until you apply it to this
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules from Joe dispenza
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
that I'll see you there I believe that
your personality creates your personal
reality and in order to change your
personal reality your life it means then
that on some level we have to change
because nothing changes in our life
unless we change